BRET?
>> Bret: STEVE HARRIGAN AT
THE SITE OF THE FUNERAL.
STEVE, THANK YOU.
♪
>> Bret: IN TONIGHT'S
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO
SEGMENT, THE AIDS EPIDEMIC.
MIKE TWEETS THE DISEASE
DOMINATED THE NEWS IN THE
80'S AND 90'S.
HOW FAR HAVE WE COME SINCE
THEN?
WELL, MIKE, TONIGHT MIKE
EMANUEL HAS SOME ANSWERS.
>> AMERICA FACES A DISEASE
THAT IS FATAL AND SPREADING
AND THIS CALLS FOR URGENCY,
NOT PANIC.
>> THERE WAS A TIME BACK IN
THE 1980S WHEN A DIAGNOSIS
OF H.I.V. WAS A DEATH
SENTENCE.
>> THE SURVIVAL WAS A YEAR
TO YEAR AND A HALF.
WHICH MEANT THAT 50% OF MY
PATIENTS WOULD BE DEAD IN A
YEAR TO A YEAR AND A HALF.
>> MORE THAN 35 YEARS LATER,
IT'S RARE TO HEAR ABOUT THE
VIRUS EVEN THOUGH MORE THAN
1.1 MILLION PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN THE U.S. WITH
H.I.V. TODAY.
ONE OF THE HIGHEST PROFILE
SURVIVORS IS BASKETBALL
GREAT MAGIC JOHNSON WHO
STUNNED THE WORLD WITH THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT BACK IN 1991.
>> SOMETIME WE THINK ONLY
GAY PEOPLE CAN GET IT.
ONLY IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN TO ME.
AND HERE I AM SAYING IT CAN
HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
EVEN ME, MAGIC JOHNSON.
IT CAN HAPPEN.
>> DR. ANTHONY FOUCHY HAS
ADVISED FIVE PRESIDENTS ON
H.I.V. AIDS AND OTHER GLOBAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
>> IN 1996 THAT WAS THE
WATERSHED MOMENT.
WHEN THE COMBINATIONS OF
DRUGS WAS SHOWN TO DECREASE
THE LEVEL OF VIRUS TO BELOW
DETECTABLE LEVELS.
AND TO KEEP THEM THERE.
>> IN 2003, PRESIDENT GEORGE
W. BUSH LAUNCHED THE
PRESIDENT'S EMERGENCY PLAN
FOR AIDS RELIEF RECOGNIZING
THE H.I.V. AIDS PANDEMIC
THREATEN TO WIPE OUT AN
ENTIRE GENERATION IN AFRICA.
>> SELDOM HAS HISTORY
OFFERED A GREATER
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO MUCH
FOR SO MANY.
WE HAVE CONFRONTED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO CONFRONT H.I.V.
AIDS IN OUR OWN COUNTRY AND
TO MEET A SEVERE AND URGENT
CRISIS ABROAD TONIGHT I PLAN
THE EMERGENCY PLAN FOR AIDS
RELIEF.
>> ROCK STAR BONO FROM U2
GAVE MR. BUSH CREDIT FOR
SAVING MILLIONS OF LIVES.
INVESTMENT HAS DELIVERED.
>> ENTIRE COMMUNITIES WERE
DISSEMINATED.
CHILDREN WERE LIVING WITHOUT
MOTHERS AND FATHERS U
SCHOOLS WENT WITHOUT
TEACHERS.
HOSPITALS WENT WITHOUT
NURSES AND DOCTORS.
AND TODAY IN THOSE SAME
AREAS WE HAVE NEARLY
13 MILLION PEOPLE ON
TREATMENT BECAUSE OF.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA NOTICED
THE INCREDIBLE TOOLS
AVAILABLE TO PREVENT AND
TREAT INFECTION.
>> WHAT ONCE SEEMED LIKE AN
IMPOSSIBLE DREAM, THE DREAM
OF AN AIDS-FREE GENERATION
IS WITHIN OUR GRASP.
>> DR. FOUCHY SAYS THE
UNITED STATES MUST AT THIS
POINT TO LEAD BECAUSE THE
FIGHT ISN'T OVER YET.
>> THE FINAL HOLY GRAIL THAT
WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD ON
IS AN H.I.V. VACCINE.
SO IF YOU LOOK AT EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENED FROM 1981 TO
TODAY IN 2018, IF WE GET
THAT VACCINE, THAT WOULD BE
THE NAIL IN THE COFFIN OF